Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin Dr. Toprak.
Ich bin die Asistenzarztin.
Ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen sprechen.
Verstanden?
Klar, gerne.
Bevor ich zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden komme,
muss ich noch eine Frage zu Ihrem Personal stellen.
Falls etwas unklar ist, unterbrechen Sie mich bitte.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Klein.
Können Sie das wiederholen?
Klein.
Klein?
K-L-E-I-N.
Ganz genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt.
Herr Thomas, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. März 1981.
81.
Herr Klein, wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin aktuell ca. 85 kg.
85.
Haben Sie ungefähr ab 30 genommen?
Nein.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Klein?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
1,75 m.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was fühlt Sie zu uns?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen,
weil ich seit nun ca. drei Tagen Schmerz im Bauch habe.
Und ich habe zuerst Ibuprofen genommen.
Damit wird das besser.
Aber es ändert sich nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten oder laut nach?
Die sind vor drei Tagen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Seit drei Tagen.
Plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Im Oberbauch.
Sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden?
Die Schmerzen sind nicht schlimmer geworden,
aber sie kommen und gehen immer wieder.
Kommen und gehen.
Sie haben Schmerzintervalle, Schmerzfreie Intervalle.
Ja, habe ich auch.
Sie haben gesagt, das Oberbauchschmerzen.
Am Echel ist es rechtsseitig oder linksseitig?
Tendenziell rechtsseitig.
Wie ist die Schmerzencharakter?
Siechen, drücken, bohren?
Das sind so stechende Schmerzen.
Stechende.
Stechende, drückende Schmerzen würde ich sagen.
Hat Ibuprofen gut geholfen?
Wie bitte?
Hat Ibuprofen?
Sie haben schon gesagt...
Aber das hält nicht immer lange an.
Das hält nur wenig an leider.
Wie viele Dosieren haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe 600 Milligramm eingenommen.
600?
Jetzt schon ca. 4 Stück oder 5 Stück habe ich eingenommen.
4 und 5 Stück?
Seit 3 Tagen, ja.
Wann war das letzte Mal, Sie haben eingenommen?
Ich habe die eingenommen zuletzt gestern Abend.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Also ich habe gemerkt, dass wenn ich esse, die Schmerzen mehr werden.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie eher in die rechte Flanke ausstrahlen.
So ein bisschen nach hinten, in den Rücken.
Rechte Flanke, hinterrücken, ja.
Wie steht die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenskala?
Von 1 bis 10?
10 ist unerträglich.
Aktuell oder wenn nicht Schmerzen da sind?
Aktuell nicht, wenn Schmerzen da ist.
Ja, würde ich sagen 7 bis 8.
Aktuell wie viele?
Aktuell habe ich vielleicht 2 oder 1.
Ich habe kaum Schmerzen aktuell.
Aber wenn ich esse, habe ich die Schmerzen nicht.
Ich habe die Schmerzen nicht.
Wenn ich esse, habe ich die Schmerzen nicht.
Ist Ihnen ein gelbes Auge oder Haut aufgefallen?
Vielleicht.
Am allersten die Augen, ja?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Jukreis?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich gemerkt, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Blechungen?
Verstopfung?
Durchfall?
Nein, alles nicht.
Sogbrennen?
Nein, ich habe nur Übelkeit.
Übelkeit?
Wenn nicht Schmerzen da sind, habe ich mehr Übelkeit.
Aber Erbrochen habe ich jetzt noch nicht.
Sie haben Übelkeit, wenn Sie etwas essen?
Ja, wenn ich die Schmerzen habe.
Schmerzen?
Aber Sie haben noch nicht Erbrochen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstoppen?
Atemrot?
Nein, nicht.
Atemrot nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen?
Wie ist die Urinfarbe und Stuhlfarbe?
Die Urinfarbe ist etwas dunkel.
Urin ist dunkel.
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass die Stuhlfarbe heller ist als sonst.
Stuhlfarbe ist heller.
Sie haben keine Sogbrennen und Lechungen?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Nein, ich habe eigentlich keine Vorerkrankungen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde als Kind an den Mandeln operiert.
Verliefer war komplikationlos?
Bei einem Kind.
Ich meine, dass die Verliefer und OP komplikationlos sind.
Ich erinnere mich kaum daran.
Ich war noch ein Kind.
Sie waren die Entschuldigung.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ich habe oft Rückenschmerzen.
Deswegen nehme ich Aponamin, Ibuprofen 600 ein.
Haben Sie bei Ihnen etwas festgestellt?
Die Rückenschmerzen, eine besondere Erkrankung?
Es wurde festgestellt beim Orthopäden,
dass ich einen beginnenden Bandscheibenvorfall habe.
Beginnenden Bandscheibenvorfall?
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Klein?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Niemand?
Ich rauche nicht.
Nehmen Sie Ankochosusig?
Ab und zu bei Feiern oder Geburtstagen.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich?
Ich muss die Patienten dieser Frage stellen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie vor Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Mein Vater hatte Prostatokrebs.
Prostatokrebs.
Genau.
Der ist operiert worden.
Meine Mutter hat Bluthochdruck und eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Die leben noch, ja?
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen großen Bruder, ja.
Mein alter Bruder.
Der Bruder ist auch gesund?
Ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin ledig.
Sie wohnen allein?
Ich wohne aktuell alleine, ja.
Sie haben keine Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie von Bericht?
Ich arbeite auf dem Bau als Maurer.
Bauarbeits?
Ich arbeite als Maurer.
Ich arbeite auf Baustellen.
Baustellen, okay.
Baustellen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich glaube schon.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
In den sechs Monaten war ich im Ausland, ja.
Ich war in Spanien.
Spanien.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, ich gehe oft spazieren, fahre Fahrrad.
Aber aktiv Sport mache ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Herr Klein?
Eigentlich nicht.
Was glauben Sie denn, was ich haben könnte?
Wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber ich habe den Verdacht auf einen Gallenstein oder Gallenverschluss.
Okay.
Am besten ist es ein Gallenstein.
Und natürlich kann es Gallenwegverschluss sein.
Ist das schlimm?
Es ist nicht schlimm.
Das kann heilbar sein.
Aber ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Waren Sie andere Fragen?
Keine Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Sie müssen etwas fragen.
Alles ganz einfach, ja.
Ja.
Vielleicht.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herr Oberarzt,
ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Darf ich ihn Ihnen vorstellen?
Natürlich gerne, bitte.
Darf ich ihn? Okay, danke.
Thomas Klein ist 45 Jahre alt, geboren am 14. März 1981.
Wegt aktuell 85 Kilogramm, 1,75 Meter groß.
1,75 Meter.
Ja, 1,75 Meter groß.
Komm, wir brauchen dich.
Komm, wir brauchen dich, ja. Okay, danke.
Er stellt sich mit seit drei Tagen erhe, rechtseitig bestehender, dauerhafter und Schmerzfreienterwahl über Bauchschmerzen vor.
Schmerzen sind nach und nach schlimm geworden.
Seit drei Tagen hat er 600 Milligramm Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Aber Ibuprofen hat wenig Wielinderung gebracht.
Schmerzen Charakter ist stechend, drückend.
Schmerzen würden rechten Flank und hinten ausstrahlen.
Schmerzen testet bei der akuten Phase bei 7 von 10.
Aktuell bei 2 bis 3 von 10.
Hat der Kolikartige Schmerzen?
Kolikartige, ja.
Hat der Kolikartige?
Ja, man kann Kolikartige stechen oder drücken.
War das Kolikartige oder sind das nur Dauerschmerzen?
Nein, Kolikartige.
Weil der Kolikartige nach und nach kommt.
Er hat einige Seiten Schmerzen im Freien Intervalle.
Das meint der Kolikartige.
Er klagt über Icterus, Cichlera Icterus.
Die Frage nach Pyrrhozes, Fieber, Pyrrhosis, Emezes, Atemnot, Tachycardie, Obstupation, Durchfall wurden verneint.
Üren ist dunkel geworden, Stuhl ist hell geworden.
Und sie klagt auch Übergheit, wenn sie Schmerzen hat.
Wenn Schmerzen hat, hat er keine Schmerzen.
In Kinderheit muss man die Schmerzen durchgeführt werden.
Und, ja, sie hat ein Schürdegang.
Er hat ein Scherbiforfall.
Ich muss erinnern.
Ich konnte nicht erinnern.
Ich muss erinnern, dass er ein Scherbiforfall hat.
Er hat keine Allergie.
Er ist kein Raucher.
Er trinkt Aponzyl, Nudel, besonders anhand des Alkohols.
Die Drogen wurden verneint.
Sein Vater leidet an Prostate Karzinoma.
Er muss operiert werden.
Die Mutter leidet Arterie Leipertoni und Hypoteroze.
Der Bruder ist gesund.
Er ist ledig.
Kein Kind wohnt allein.
Er arbeitet als Mauer im Baustell.
Er war in Spanien.
Er treibt keinen Sport.
Was meinen Sie mit Spanien?
Als Reisernahmese.
Sie müssen einen Satz machen.
Ja, genau.
Hat das eine Relevanz, dass der Spanier war?
Ich denke, nein.
Brauchen Sie nichts zu sagen, oder?
Muss man eigentlich nicht sagen.
Nur wenn es eine Relevanz hat.
Wahrscheinlich.
Dann muss man sagen.
Sie meinen, das wäre ein Fernostland?
Nein, Fernost nicht.
Warum?
Japan oder Korea kann man es erwähnen.
Wenn es eine Relevanz hat, wegen der Erkrankung.
Und Sie das für Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose relevant halten.
Dann können Sie das erwähnen.
Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Patient Diarrhohen hat.
Oder Fieber mit Diarrhohen hat.
Und dann fragt man ja schon, waren Sie im Ausland?
Oder wenn er komische Gliederschmerzen hat.
Ob er von einer Zecke gebissen wurde.
Oder ob er Malaria gehabt hat.
Oder weiß ich nicht.
Man kann sagen, die Reisernahmese war unauffällig.
Oder ist unauffällig.
Das kann man sagen.
Nur einfach aufzählen.
Sie haben ja nur abgelesen.
Von wegen, Kinder hatte er nicht.
War in Spanien etc.
Man muss schon einen Satz mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Genau.
Reisernahmese ist unauffällig.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Das ist gut.
Aber im Falle gibt es eine Sistioziozis.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Das einige Keimen kann diese Gallenwege befallen.
Oder nicht.
Sistioziozis. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Eine Parasite.
Das wissen wir ja noch gar nicht.
Man kann sagen, die Reisernahmese war.
Sie können auch sagen, der war in Spanien gewesen.
Im Sommer oder so.
Können Sie erwähnen.
Aber war in Spanien.
Das ist dann, wann war er in Spanien?
Vorgestern, vor drei Jahren.
Wann war er in Spanien?
Oder war er in Spanien schon erkrankt etc.
Genau.
Man sollte schon einen Satz draus machen.
Nicht nur ablesen.
Das meine ich damit.
Genau.
Das war alles.
Habe ich etwas vergessen.
War er beim Haushalt schon gewesen?
Ich habe vergessen.
Diese Frage stellen.
Muss man fragen, ob er deswegen schon mal beim Haushalt gewesen ist.
Ob das bei ihm bekannt ist.
Ob er schon vorher solche Beschwerden in seiner Jugend gehabt hat.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Nein.
Ich habe vergessen.
Ich musste fragen.
Das war der erste Befall.
Genau.
Haben Sie das schon mal gehabt?
Vielleicht kennt er die Schmerzen.
Vielleicht weiß er was er hat.
Genau.
Sie haben etwas gut vorgestellt.
Was für eine Verdachtstheorie.
Am besten die Analyse der Analyse.
Eine Verschlussart.
Aufgrund einer Gallenstein.
Eine Gallenstein kann es sein.
Genau.
Was noch?
Eine Gallenstein.
Wie nennt man das?
Aufgrund einer Cholodstyletiasis.
Vermutlich eine Cholodocholetiasis.
Ja.
Cholodetiasis oder Styletiasis.
Genau.
Kann sein.
Was machen Sie an Diagnostik?
Was haben Sie vor?
Ja.
Diagnostik.
Ich muss die Patientin palpieren.
Die ist die Mörfe zeigen.
Das war Mörfe?
Ja.
Das war Mörfe.
Ich muss beachten die Mörfe zeigen.
Und wie Gallenblasen.
Ist Prahl oder
ein Tespar oder Schmerzhaft.
Und
auch die Hautfarbe ist wichtig.
Hautfarbe eine ist.
Gibt es eine
Ikterus zeigen.
Natürlich
ist Ultraschall wichtig.
Blut.
Blut untersuchen.
Leberwerten.
Alkalenphosphatasen.
Gamma-Glutamin
Transaminasen.
Und Nierenwerten.
Und Enzymewerten.
Und Blutbild.
Und Lirubin auch?
Lirubin auch. Natürlich.
Genau.
Und was machen Sie noch?
In der Ambulanz?
Urin untersuchen.
Man kann die
Urinwert
bewerten.
Und?
Was machen Sie noch?
Diagnostisch.
In der Ambulanz?
Sie meinen das Bildgebendeverfahren oder
eine Laboruntersuchung?
Nicht Laborunterzüge. Das haben Sie schon gesagt.
Ja. Okay.
Was würde ich machen?
Okay. Untersuchen.
Sie meinen das alles
Untersuchen oder?
Als diagnostisches Verfahren. Was machen Sie?
Ja, das ist noch diagnostisch.
Tomografie kann sein.
Ne.
MRCP?
Auch nicht.
ERCP? Auch nicht.
Was machen Sie in der Ambulanz?
Sie meinen das
Therapie?
Nein. Diagnostisch.
Er kommt, hat Schmerzen.
Sie haben mit ihm gesprochen.
Nehmen Blut ab. Was machen Sie noch sofort?
Bei diesen Beschwerden?
EKG?
Ultraschall.
Optom- und Sonografie.
Aber hier habe ich gesagt,
das ist o...
Okay. Wenn Sie gesagt haben, okay, dann habe ich nicht gehört.
Aber ich habe nicht gehört, dass Sie Ultraschall
vom Optom gesagt haben. Aber vielleicht
habe ich nicht gehört. Okay.
Sie machen einen Ultraschall
Genau. Natürlich. Erstes ist Ultraschall.
Genau. Und dann haben Sie einen Ultraschall gemacht.
Und dann, was machen Sie?
Wenn Sie sehen...
Was sehen Sie dann wahrscheinlich?
Wenn Sie jetzt einen Verdacht auf eine
Schule doch oder Thesis haben.
Was sehen Sie dann im Ultraschall?
Kann man direkt die Steine sehen?
Kann man eine vergroßerte
Gallenblase feststellen?
Richtig.
Eine Flüssigkeit neben diesen
Gallenblasen.
Dann wäre es entzündet.
Ja, entzündet.
Aber es muss nicht unbedingt entzündet sein.
Wer keine Schule
zystiert, ist.
Okay. Die
die Groß...
Groß von diesen
Gallenblasen kann man
messen auch die. Ja, genau.
Wenn die ist auch verdünnert.
Man kann zum Beispiel
gucken, ob es eine
Intrahepatische Scholastase,
eine Intrahepatische Scholastase gibt.
Das kann man sich auch angucken.
Was ich damit sagen möchte, ist,
man
muss...
Man kann im Ultraschall schon viel
sehen. Man muss nicht unbedingt ein
CT machen deswegen.
Ja, genau.
Aber man kann natürlich auch, wenn man
im Ultraschall das nicht gut sieht,
auch eine MRCP machen,
um zu sehen, wo der Verschluss ist.
Ob es ein Stein ist
oder ob es ein Pankreaskopfkarzinom ist.
Kann ja auch sein.
Ob es eine...
Auch eine Kompression,
also eine mechanische Ursache
sein könnte. Das kann man
im Ultraschall meistens gut sehen.
Genau.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Ja, ich würde
sofort
den Veneo in den Eingang einlegen.
Die Oral-Einnahme ist
karenz.
Bei den
Anzündung parametern
ist er hoch.
Ihr habt jetzt gesehen, dass Sie
einen Stein
im Duktus Cholodochus haben.
Ja. Der hat sich.
Da ist ein Stein, der verschließt
den Gannengang.
Genau.
Wir müssen Oral-Einnahme
stoppen.
Wir müssen
Oral-Einnahme stoppen.
Entravenöse?
Ja, Entravenöse natürlich.
Okay. Und was noch?
Was machen wir als... Wir haben die Blutwerte gesehen.
Die Blutwerte sind
vielleicht... Also wenig Entzündungszeichen,
aber er hat schon
Cholostasewerte. Bidderubin ist erhöht,
GUT, GPT
und AP ist erhöht.
Und was machen Sie mit dem jetzt therapeutisch?
Nehmen Sie den stationär auf
oder schicken Sie ihn nach Hause?
Natürlich. Wir müssen
Stationäre einlegen.
Sofort.
Dann? Dann müssen wir
RRCP führen.
Ja, ganz genau.
Die richtige... Die Stein...
Die muss Stein rausnehmen.
Ganz genau.
Machen Sie das in der Nacht? Wenn er zum Beispiel
nachts kommt, nachts um 12 Uhr,
machen Sie das
in der Nacht oder warten Sie bis nächsten Morgen?
Wahrscheinlich
normalerweise
wir können... Wir haben nicht so viele
Experten mit dem
RRCP.
Wenn die Experten da sind,
können wir... Genau.
Sie können bis zum nächsten Morgen warten.
Ja.
Normalerweise, wenn der Bidderubinwert
nicht zu hoch ist,
wenn da jetzt nicht dramatische Werte sind,
dann muss man das nicht als Notfall machen,
sondern kann das am nächsten Morgen machen.
Genau.
Sehr gut.
Musste man diese Antibiose
einleiten? Mit dem...
Ich glaube, man
macht momentan eine Single-Shot-Antibiose.
Weil man...
Also eine einmalige Antibiose, glaube ich.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das muss ich nachlesen, weil
man mit der RRCP
auch eine Pancreatitis verursachen kann.
Ich glaube,
das macht man Single-Shot, aber ich weiß das nicht ganz genau.
Ich muss das nochmal nachlesen.
Ich glaube,
man macht eine einmalige Antibiose.
Ich glaube, aber ich muss das nachlesen.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Genau.
Was kommt als Differentialdiagnostik noch infrage?
Ja,
Differentialdiagnostik kann
sein, dass Lebefaktoren
oder Pancreasfaktoren
Lebefaktoren...
Wie meinen Sie Faktoren?
Ursache, ich meine das.
Was? Sagen Sie was.
Das kann eine virale
Infektion, Hepatitis A
oder fulminale Hepatitis A
sein.
B auch?
B nicht so fulminale.
B geht
langsam.
Und natürlich
diese Hepatitis A
und Hepatitis C
Pancreasfaktoren
Kölnfaktoren
andere Faktoren.
Was kann man noch?
Ja, das ist schon
recht viel.
Neben Organe Ursachen,
ganz genau.
Nephruletiasis, würde ich sagen,
ist keine Differentialdiagnose,
macht normalerweise kein Iterus
und ist auch nicht nahrungsabhängig.
Eine Kollegin hat geschrieben,
Nephruletiasis, aber
Nephruletiasis ist nicht
nahrungsabhängig. Bei diesen Patienten
ist er aber nahrungsabhängig.
Wenn er isst, dann hat er Schmerzen.
Nephruletiasis haben sie immer
Schmerzen und Kohligartig
und die sind nicht auszuhalten.
Ja gut, gibt es Fragen
ihrerseits? Oder aus dem
Kollegen-Kreis hier?
Gibt es Ergänzungen? Haben wir was
falsch gemacht? Müssen wir was
verbessern? Haben wir etwas
vergessen zu sagen?
Keiner möchte sprechen.
Sie haben
gut erklärt.
Herr Oberhaus,
Sie haben gut erklärt alles.
Okay, dann weiß jeder Bescheid,
weiß jeder, was er machen muss.
Am nächsten Mal.
Gut, wenn keine
Fragen sind, dann
haben Sie das gut gemacht, Herr Toprak?
Nein, danke.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Am 30. Oktober.
Dann wünsche ich schon mal jetzt
viel Erfolg. Hast du hier Fachgebiet?
Was machen Sie normalerweise?
Ich bin Gynäkologen.
Gynäkologen, okay.
Dieses Bereich ist nicht so
bekannt für mich, aber
das sind so Basics.
Das sind so Basics.
Ichteros kann
nicht so viel sein.
Kann man eine Handvoll abzählen.
Ichteros normalerweise.
Schmerzen und dann
nicht schmerzhafte
Ichteros und Fieber
hat er auch nicht gehabt und so was.
Das ist alles eigentlich ein ganz
einfacher Fall gewesen für Sie.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Außer diesem Topik.
Ich habe einige
Anamesen gelesen.
Beide Fremdanamesen.
Zum Beispiel Fremdanamesen Kind.
Kind ist sieben Jahre oder acht Jahre.
Im Falle
eines Diabetes Kind.
Die nehmen die Information
auch von den Großeltern
Seite auch. Sie fragen
die Großeltern Kindheit. Aber
eine Seite nicht beide Seiten.
Gibt es eine Besüchtigung
oder das war die normale Situation?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht. Also normalerweise
fragt man ja automatisch den Patienten.
Bei Kindern
meinen Sie Pelliatrie oder meinen Sie jetzt
bei Erwachsenen?
Bei Kindern.
Bei Kindanamese.
Zum Beispiel acht Jahre.
Ja, es gibt da vielleicht Typ 1 Diabetes in der Familie.
Ja. Aber
muss man Großeltern
fragen auch? Großeltern?
Ja, kann man fragen doch.
Aber
Sie fragen nur einseitig. Großeltern
Mutterseitig oder Vaterseitig?
Muss man beide
Seiten fragen? Das weiß ich nicht.
Normalerweise fragt man beide Seiten.
Also ich frage beide Seiten.
Aber ich weiß nicht
ob das nur einseitig vererbt wird.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.